two years after 13 reasons why premiered
on Netflix they have decided to edit out
a controversial suicide scene from the
teen drama series I think at the end of
the day everyone on the show is very
committed to to telling the story and
the most thought that most authentic way
possible Netflix made the decision after
consulting a medical expert and the Edit
was made with the support from the
show's creator Brian your key quote
we've heard from many young people that
13 reasons why encourage them to start
conversations about difficult issues
like depression and suicide and get help
often for the first time as we prepare
to launch season 3 later this summer
we've been mindful about the ongoing
debate around the show the show also
included a link for anyone needing help
finding crisis resources make sure that
those links and resources are provided
for people if they need it
of course the scene in question depicted
the graphic suicide of Katherine
Langford it's character Hanna which
served as the catalyst for the plot of
the season
it's an emotional story and I think that
with season 1 it's all growing up to a
very kind of a huge emotional climax and
we know that from the get-go
now the entire scene has been removed
leaving only the scene following it
where her parents find her body
shortly after Netflix announced the news
Yorkie shared his own statement
expressing support for the decision and
explaining the intent behind the
disturbing scene in the context of this
story quote our creative intent in
portraying the ugly painful reality of
suicide in such graphic detail in season
1 was to tell the truth about the horror
of such an act and make sure no one
would ever wish to emulate it no one
scene is more important to the life of
the show and it's message that we must
take better care of each other we
believe this edit will help the show do
the most good for the most people while
mitigating any risk for especially
vulnerable young viewers we cover a lot
of issues that are really personal and
really relevant and so I think it's
gonna affect people differently
depending on who they are and what
they've gone through
the show premiered in March 2017 too
much controversy at the time Selena
Gomez who serves as an executive
producer on the series told et what she
hoped people took away from the show I
think kids especially with social media
sometimes they just feel a little
claustrophobic and I don't think their
voice is actually being heard and I
think that's the message I want I want
people to know that every every single
life is valuable that their voice can be
heard and that there are people who are
willing to be there for them the third
season of 13 reasons why is expected to
hit Netflix later this year without
Catherine Langford the actress confirmed
her departure from the show to ET in
2018 Hanna Hanna is rapt Hanna is
officially done on 13 reasons why and
you know I feel really proud to have
been a part of the project and I think
that 13 reasons why you know even though
if I'm not honest isn't in a season
three her story is something I'm gonna
carry with me and I think also a lot of
other people are gonna carry with them
and I just hope that if anything I can
be there in a small way on social media
season three is sure to be a good one
and we'll be here to break all the
latest thirteen reasons why news so make
sure to keep it locked right here on ET
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye
for now
[Music]